- Most people think of Hell
as a place where bad people go
and it just gets worse for them.
I'd like to think of Hell
as where bad people go
and everyone that does bad
things meets each other.
And they can talk it out,
kinda like a therapy group.
(dramatic music)
I think, right now I'm at a stage
where I'm kind of confused with religion.
- Religion matters to me.
Cause if people don't believe in God,
then they won't go to Heaven.
And it's better to be in Heaven than Hell.
- That's a good question.
It's just a big part of
my life, I don't know.
- If you did bad sins in your life
and never ask for forgiveness,
you go to Hell where you're punished
for when you're dead.
- Most people who do bad things
are also not very mentally stable
and that's not always their fault.
- If people kill people, I
think they'll go to Hell.
- Okay.
I'm gonna kind of base it
off the Nether in Minecraft.
Take a portal to go there
and there's a lot of bad creatures.
- I think cats are evil.
Hell might be full of cats.
- And there's fire everywhere
and it's all red and orange and yellow.
- I think the Devil or Jesus
decides if you go to Hell.
- I don't think of it as like
a Devil or you're on fire.
It could just be like you're
asleep and you never come up.
I mean, that could be what death is like.
You're never gonna know
until you find out.
- I think Hell might be underground.
All red and dark volcanoes.
- I almost don't wanna use red
because that's not really
how I want to think of Hell.
- Ooh, I found red!
- I imagine it's really hot.
- I think it would be even hotter than LA.
The Devil, see?
- In my religion, we call it Sheitan.
- I think the volcanoes are
always erupting in Hell.
- I imagine it's something
bad like carrying
a whole big wheelbarrow
full of heavy stuff.
- I think people go to Hell forever.
- If you do bad things,
you go to Hell and there's not way out.
- After you go to Hell,
you can go to Heaven because
it's made you a better person.
It would make no sense to let these people
burn or be with the Devil.
I think it'd be cooler
if we could help them.
- Meow.
- What's a politician?
- There's a person that should go to Hell.
That person shall remain nameless.
Yeah. (laughs)
- This is just a devil cat, I guess.
Like an evil cat.
- Maybe Hell is short
for help or helpfulness
and maybe someone said,
"Add an L instead of the P!"
And someone said, "Okay."
- There's a really bad red ground.
There's a really, really bad evil person
having to pull a whole
load of heavy stuff.
Here's a Sheitan.
- First you get this big blue arch
when you walk in and it says help is here.
And this was a big sign that said Hell
in the original beginning,
but now it says help
because we've crossed it out
and that's how I think of Hell.
Animal therapy.
We have our little taxi
that drove you here
with a very happy driver.
Food, where people go to socialize
and eat their healthy food
because health food makes you happier.
- This is all the lava,
the red stuff and the pink.
The gray stuff is the
ground of the volcanoes.
- It's a really, really bad place
and I suggest you apologize
for every bad thing you've done
and never ever do anything
bad unless you want
to end up like this
really, really evil person.
- Think of if you have a loved one
who did something very bad
or murdered someone and
you're watching this video.
This is how I want you
to think that they are.
If they've passed away, I
think they're getting help.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't know if this is real or not,
but if it is, I really
imagine this is what Hell is.
(upbeat music)